well it was a big day here on the do
barrymore show because i was surprised
by two of my all-time favorites you know
i watched 90 days beyonce and i watch
all the spin-offs ah drew surprised me
on the show with stacy and darcy
hello hi how dare you
[Music]
how are you doing i actually feel so
happy right now i feel free george and i
are no longer together i felt like it
was the right thing for me to do now i'm
ready to live life again for myself and
love me more you know we have a lot of
single men watching uh right now i'm not
going to throw anything out there what
you're looking for hey guys send me a dm
hey it goes down in this yeah baby i
love that well let's talk a little 90
day i mean it all kind of started there
do you have any regrets about going on
that show
no actually i feel like it led us to
where we are today and even though i
have
had all these breakups on the show
makeup breakups you know i feel like
we're very authentic and real and a lot
of women you know men can relate to it
so i feel like if we can help other
people then that's all well worth it and
nothing's off limits on the show i mean
we followed you getting complete yeah
complete transformation twerky and
diapers yeah
so when that happens when when that airs
is it like are you fully comfortable
watching it back are there any moments
of like
i think we know what we filmed so we
looked at some more good yeah
i wish it was a two-hour show yeah me
too
can you still watch 90 day now that
you've been through it can you watch the
other seasons you can't is it hard to
see your ex falling in love with someone
else you know what not really i kind of
like i read and kind of see through it
all you know they deserve happiness and
love to you but um some people are real
some people aren't
oh god you know that's good because i
know what you're saying but i'm not
saying i understand is there a favorite
couple of all time on 90 day i love amy
and david yeah really nice and sweet
we've met them many times and i love you
all yes yeah i love them i watch their
they have a special yeah i know i know
lauren and alexis are cool sexy like
yeah yeah
yeah is there anyone that you um would
fast forward through oh the the one that
larissa was with i don't know really
oh cool
i like cole and his mom yeah everybody's
like teach their own yeah i think they
should have like a tlc con where like
all of you come right and all the super
fans go yeah oh in fact you know what
ross matthews presents tlc con it's a
new business it's copyrighted sorry
okay let's talk about being a twin
really quickly i've always wondered what
that's like you have this twin
connection do you find yourself having
those twin moments where you think about
her and she'll call you
yeah yeah we'll have that throughout our
life when we were younger we'd have the
same dreams yeah
we'd wake up and you know tell each
other what we dreamt about right very
similar or you know sometimes we'd have
the same outfit on without knowing that
we put on the same outfit so like kind
of like today yeah today wait this was
not planned we actually went to the same
store we both picked it up same time and
we're like i'm gonna wear that on the
show and she's like i wanted to wear it
too so we decided let's just
twin it to put it up today that's so
cute and then i was in my dressing room
thinking like what color do i want to
wear today and i went i just randomly
picked these and then you're watching
all matching in a triplet kind of way
yeah i got pink in here
this is a dream come true thank you
[Music]
you